today we're reviewing amd's
rx 6700 xt it's supposed to be 480
and out on the market uh march 18th so
we're actually able to post the reviews
a day in advance this time which is nice
because in this market in the very least
if the reviews go up the same day no
one's going to watch the reviews they're
going to buy the card first and then
decide if they want it later
because otherwise you might not get a
card so this is going to
up one day in advance you do have time
to actually watch this and determine
whether you want the card
before you buy one and then all the
partner models will be launching
on the same day so all on march 18th
with a starting price of in theory 480
for
the manufacturer's suggested price and
we'll see how that goes
but this is a 40 cu card it is cut down
quite a bit the
gp die is actually different silicon's
uh different size we'll look at that the
tear down
then in the 6800 and the 6800 xt cards
and today we're gonna be benchmarking
this for gaming ray tracing
rasterization thermals frequency
power and more before that this video is
brought to you by the thermaltake tower
100. thermaltake's tower 100 is a mini
itx case to serve as a showcase system
for your components
the tower 100 has received many
revisions since we first saw it
and the case now has an open vent in the
bottom for intake
a mesh cut out in the side panel for
some gpu ventilation
and additional mesh along the side
skirts and the side panels of the case
the tower 100 is mostly focused on
building a showpiece pc
that's small enough to fit on most
tables learn more at the link in the
description below
so we already have a specs and news
announcement video on the 6700xt
on the channel if you want to check it
out the problem with launching
any video card right now is the same
thing we said in the rtx 3060 review
the rtx 3060 launched into a market
where the price didn't matter
it's totally irrelevant what nvidia sets
as the price how many they make
because they're gonna sell them
regardless and so that makes it a little
bit difficult to review gpus
typically we lean heavily on the msrp as
a basic guide you're expecting plus or
minus 100
at most from msrp not
whatever it is right now and so in this
market
as we said in the rtx 3060 review you
don't need to launch a good product
your video card doesn't need to be good
it doesn't need to be competitive
all it needs to do is exist that's how
you sell a video card
in this market and unfortunately that
means there's really not
as many competitive practices coming
into play as usually the manufacturers
aren't pushing each other down in price
because why would they even if one
manufacturer comes in
under the other one for price they're
just selling themselves short because
they're going to sell the cards anyway
so what's the point of being 20 or 40
cheaper
it might be better value this card like
the 30 60
might be in kind of math territory we'll
talk about that today but does it matter
if it's in
meh territory if it's going to sell out
anyway
and the answer to that is basically no
it doesn't matter because it is going to
sell out
and so it doesn't matter if things
aren't exciting if they stagnate if you
end up paying one dollar
for one percentage point like you did
with the 30 60 and like we'll see today
mostly with this card but anyway the
basic specs of this thing
it's 40 ceus so it's cut down it's a
smaller die the advertised game clock
and
giant air quotes there is 24 24
megahertz we'll look at the actual
frequency in reality in a little bit in
charts
the memory capacity is 12 gigabytes gdr6
that's plenty
don't let anyone tell you you need 16
gigabytes you barely need 12.
and by the way as a reminder the
memory number you see in gpuz and
hardware info
whatever that's just an allocation for
security reasons
those applications do not know how much
memory is actually being used
by the applications on the gpu all they
know is
what's been allocated so if the
application if gpuz or hardware info
says
10 gigabytes it's probably because the
application requested 10 gigabytes it
doesn't mean that it's actually using
that
so if it requests 10 and it gets 8 but
it's only using 6
then it doesn't matter you have enough
capacity either way
anyway that's just a that's a separate
topic but wanted to make sure that's
clear for this one
so 12 is fine for a card of this class 6
is maybe borderline okay
uh future looking though it becomes more
of a problem especially with ray tracing
in some of these applications board
power is advertised at 230 watts we'll
do power testing in a bit
scp again is 480 scp is
amd's word that means msrp it's prepared
to cringe
suggested retail price but supposed to
be 480
we're going to base our evaluation on
that number even if it's not
as likely to hold because we need to
base it on something
and so we're going to go with what the
companies are setting as msrp because
that tells us
what they think the card is worth and
where it's supposed to be positioned
so enough of that let's get into the
benchmarks for today go through a lot of
them and then talk about conclusions we
like to begin our gpu reviews with
frequency validation this helps us
establish that the gpu is
actually working properly and running as
it should before we waste any time with
testing
if it's not this chart has a truncated
chart range on the left
axis from 2250 to 2600 megahertz
it's helpful for visualizing differences
that otherwise would be difficult to see
but keep in mind that it distorts the
scale that's intentional here the rx
6800 xt stock card ran in the range of
2300 to 2360 megahertz
the rx 6800 non xt held a fairly flat
frequency near 22
80 megahertz and the rx 6700 xt was
closer to 2560 megahertz
this is normal typically amd's lower end
radeon cards run a higher frequency but
the reduction in cores and physical
hardware is what pulls down the
performance ranking
the line isn't flat which is due to
power limits and
the frequency bouncing off of a wall but
this can be flattened if desired by
boosting the power limit
in the gpu's options radeon settings
but of course then the power consumption
would go up this next chart shows the
thermals and fan speed on the amd rx
6700 xt
as a reminder the 6800xc reference card
ran nearly at 100
degrees for its junction temperature in
this test with its average edge
temperature in the range of 75 degrees
this also is a measure of v-bios not
just the cooler since we're showing
automatic settings
with auto-v bios a temperature target
will dictate the fan speed more than
anything else
amd has temperature ranges in there that
it's targeting
and the end result is a hot gpu core
with andy's default configuration
this is something that partners have
complete control over so you'll see this
change from card to card
let's get the 6700 xt on the chart now
the 6700xt
fan rpm at about 1700 is where we'd
expect it based on previous amd
reference launches
the average edge temperature is again
around 75 to 77 degrees celsius
the junction temperature stays in the
90s and as we'll show an overclock step
in it's not shy to hit 100 degrees under
the right conditions
the core can technically handle 110c
here
but it'll start throttling at that point
and 100 is still
warmer than it really needs to be the
delta of 25 to 30 degrees
edge to junction is also a wider gulf
than what we'd like to see
but this aligns with amd's mounting
pressure shortcomings
and some of the shortcomings in the
vapor chamber and the cold plate that
we've shown previously
here's our overclock stepping chart this
is basically a chart of our raw notes
while we
work through stabilizing and overclock
amd is still somewhat challenging to
work with and it behaves more
erratically than nvidia does during the
oc process
but we did establish a slight gain at
full stock our baseline score was 58 64
points in port royal
which increased by 1.3 percent just from
setting the power limit to 1
15 percent and doing nothing else
undervolting helped a little bit
but you'll see that our lower attempt at
1140 millivolts
ended up resulting in worse performance
or in performance regression in other
words
we got uplift at 1160 millivolts and it
does run below that but it silently
ends up lower in performance so it'll
work and won't throw a blue screen or
anything
but it's not better so just remember to
always validate your overclocks or your
voltage changes with actual benchmarks
for performance
to make sure you're not making it worse
accidentally the end result was a 5.6
uplift in port royal there may be some
more room in there but
we had memory errors with higher memory
overclocks and stability issues with
higher core clocks
so we'd really have to invest a lot of
time to tune it much better than this
we'll start with something different in
rainbow six siege at 1080p we measured
the amd rx 6700xc stock card at 371 fps
average with
lowest spaced proportionally and well at
255 fps and 238 fps one percent and 0.1
percent
the 371 result places the 6700 xt
between the rtx 3070 and rtx 3060 ti
that's below where it needs to be really
the
nvidia rtx 3070s msrp is 500
so there's not enough of a price gap
between the 6700 xt
and the 3070 msrp to establish a
strength in this benchmark we're still
using msrps as a guideline or a judge
because that's where the companies are
intending to sell these things that's
how they value them
everything else is just chaos and we
can't predict it for a review
but obviously you'll need to tweak your
understanding of the data based on
what's available and how much it costs
when you check inventory
the 6700xt does fine we just think it
needs to be cheaper to compete in the
fantasy gpu league
where everything goes for actual msrp
the 6800 outperforms the 6700xt by about
here that goes up later with the 6800 xt
about 18 percent ahead of the 6700xt
overclocking the 6700xt got us at 4.6
uplift moving to 388fps average at 1440p
the 6700xd pushes 228 fps average
enough to satisfy most high refresh
displays even at 1440p
and so it landed between the 3060 ti and
the 2080 super
sam or rebar would help a bit here but
we've already covered that in our 6800xt
review
and it's something that's available to
both parties now the percentages scale
like this
the 6800xt leads by 42 the 6800 non-xt
leads by 21
and the 3070 leads by 21 without either
platform using rebar overclocking
resulted in a gain of 7.6 percent for
the 6700 xt
at 4k the 6700xt ends up still doing
well at 100 fps
that's good enough to play even for a
competitive game like this one
the end result is just below the 2080
super and allows the 3060 ti a lead of
about 20
this is expected as nvidia tends to
scale better as the resolution increases
as compared to amd or again said
inversely amd does better at 1080p
than nvidia does proportionally next up
is shadow of the tomb raider at 1080p
the rx 6700 xt lands at 165 fps average
which has it above the rtx 3060 ti
and functionally equivalent to the
nvidia rtx 3070.
this is a more favorable position than
in rainbow six siege
and the amd card looks a little more
competitive here
the rx 6800 non-xt out does the new
xt by 5.5 with the rx 6800 xc out
ranking it by 11
we're at a cpu bind at this level with
the rtx 3080 and the rx 6800 xt
so we'll need higher resolutions to see
scaling as for overclocking the
improvement here
is three percent there's probably a
little bit more in there
but we had trouble with stability across
all the games when running higher
at 1440p fps falls to 119 fps average
with lows still well spaced and
indicative of strong frame time
consistency the 119
fps average result has the 6700 xt
between the rtx 3070 stock
and the amd rx 6800 the rx 6800 leads
the 6700 xt by 18
with the 6800 xt leading by 38
the overclock gave us a couple percent
once again but not much
at 4k the 6700 xt can still play the
game well with its 66 fps average and 60
fps one percent lows
the rtx 3070 is again functionally tied
the 3060 ti is a bit behind and the 6800
offers a meaningful uplift that's
actually worth establishing this
separate sku for the game looks much
better for the 6700 xt than rainbow six
did
which made it look poorly positioned
we'll still need more game data though
to make an aggregate decision redded
redemption 2 is next this one has the
6700 xd at 134 fps average for 1080p
which has it ahead of the rtx 3070 by
nine percent
that's good positioning for the gpu as
compared to rainbow six
compared to the 5700 xt there's a
generational step here
of 34 but that is
paired with a pricing increase of 80
on the 6700 xt so it doesn't really feel
like an actual improvement when we're
looking at 30 percent for
80 dollars more than the previous
generation with the same
basic naming scheme it starts to sort of
feel like nvidia's rtx 3060 launch
stagnation as long as the gpu exists
in this market it'll sell so no one
needs to care about pushing the needle
for value
at 1440p the rx 6700xt holds 101 fps
average
or still about 29 hiked generationally
over the 5700 xt the 6700 xt result has
it functionally equivalent to the rtx
and a couple percent ahead of the rtx
3060 ti the rx 6800 outperforms the rx
6700 xt by around 10
here with the 6800 xe offering about a
24 to 25
uplift the most direct nvidia
competition would be the rtx 3060 ti
below the 6700 xt or the rtx 3070.
those aren't meaningfully different
between these cards and average
isn't meaningfully different between the
30 70 and the 6700 xt
but the 3060 ti does get left behind
here at 4k
red dead redemption has the rx 6700xt
still in playable territory
but with 0.1 percent dips that start to
sometimes hurt a little bit the rtx 3070
holds a 10.5 percent lead at 4k
pulling away when it was otherwise equal
at the lower resolutions
generationally amd pushes the needle by
against its rx 5700 xt architecture uh
and previous card
and the 5700 xt ends up holding on to
its scaling better
as the resolution is pumped upwards or
worded inversely
the 6700xt scales better at lower
resolutions
than the 5700 xt did either way one of
those is true and that's why we see this
difference in scaling as the resolution
changes
in either case the value proposition
gets worse as the resolution goes up
especially compared to previous price
positioning as
now you're at a hard one dollar per one
percent improvement metric
just like we talked about with the rtx
3060 that's not
innovation that's stagnation because yes
it's better
but you're paying a proportionate amount
more so nothing's changed
that means the bar hasn't really moved
and the lower resolutions in the very
least as
some semblance of value offers slightly
better than one-to-one scaling here's a
quick frame time plot
overall they're really not too terrible
for the performance level we're getting
but there are a few small hitches lower
is better as always but more consistent
is best
we see a few hitches and corrections
toward the beginning where we see a plus
or minus change maximally of seven to
eight milliseconds
so it's occasionally noticeable but it's
really not too bad we're testing using
the previous patch for cyberpunk 2077
for gpus right now due to
stability issues of the new one but our
cpu testing uses the newest patch so
they definitely can't be compared these
were all tested using the same game
version which is the important part
so they're all directly comparable in
the gpu charts
at 1080p the rx 6700xt ran at 97 fps
average
which has it above the 5700 xt by about
but it allowed the 360 ti a lead of
about six percent
that's better positioning for the 3060
ti than elsewhere when compared to the
6700 xt
at 1440p the 6700xt remained in about
the same place
it's above the 5700 xt now by 21
while the 3060 ti maintains a slight
lead over the new amd card
the 6800 xt offers a larger jump than
elsewhere
at 41 improved over the 6700 xt
there's not much point to testing 4k
with this card in this game
but it at least proves that there's not
much point to doing it
because it's a stretch for cyberpunk
2077 to play at 4k
the card ran at 31 fps average anything
shy of an rtx 3080 here
is a rough experience in this chart in
gta 5 we're mostly bound by the cpu at
the high end so
we can't see the true difference between
the 6700xt of the 6800xt
although there's still a clear gap
against the rtx 3070.
let's move on to 1440p for more scaling
insight
1440p has the rx 6700xt at 133 fps
average scaling over the 5700 xt by 21
again back down to about a one dollar
per one percent gain metric
the new trend here is that the
improvements people think they're seeing
generationally are being obfuscated
by marketing sorcery it's getting tough
to tell when there's actually
a movement forward or progression
over the years versus when it just looks
better on a chart if you ignore the
price
scaling overall for the 6700 xt is less
impressive against its predecessor
when tested in this older title but it's
also less impressive when tested at
higher resolutions
so that's leaving a limited window to
where we're seeing the larger gains
it's still gta that is among the top
played games on steam
and many other top games are built
similarly the 3060 ti and the rtx 3070
alike
are getting outdone by the 6700 xt here
so it gets credit for defeating nvidia's
latest offerings in that sense
the 6700 xt offers a gain of about 4.3
over the rtx 3070 in gta at this
resolution
but it does move around a little bit
depending on the game at 4k the rx
6700xt plunges to 61 fps average
this is now only 12 percent better than
the 5700 xt
the rtx 3070 also passes the 6700xt now
with a 17
advantage so a complete flip and these
more expensive
rx 6800 non xt hold 78 fps average so
there's
a void like 28 lead
over the 6700xt fortunately this void
can be overcome with a bridge the the
bridge is made out of money but
you can overcome it nonetheless strange
brigade will be our last rasterized
benchmark we'll look at some power and
ray tracing numbers
after this at 1440p this one ranked the
6700 xt at 185 fps average or 191 fps
hours when overclocked
the placement is as before it's between
the rtx 3070
and the amd rx 6800 but in a manner
which is
better value than both in this instance
the price still feels too high for the
rx 6700 xt
just like it did for the rtx 3060 but
neither company feels particularly
compelled
to apply a competitive pressure right
now they'd just be selling themselves
short in this market
at 4k the rx 6700 xt stock car did 96
fps average so
including the lows it's functionally
equivalent to the rtx 3070. the rx
6700xt out does the 3060 ti
marginally and the 3070 now technically
surpasses it
but it's basically the same this is the
same trend we saw earlier
so lower resolutions benefit the 6700xt
more
quake 2 is the first of our ray tracing
games this is the first amd gpu we've
done
since the game was updated to allow
launching with amd cards
so the 6700xd is alone on this chart
amongst nvidia's cart
the update also added support for vulkan
extensions but the game appears to work
just as well
using the rtx extensions that we've used
for testing all the nvidia cards so far
we validated this and saw no performance
difference from our test configuration
so either one seems okay here the 6700xt
lands between the rtx 2060 ko
and the 2070 xc in performance at 52 fps
average
but it had a marginally more stable 0.1
percent low
nvidia's 360 ti averaged 78 fps in this
test
which is a significant 52 percent lead
over the amd card amd's 6700xc would
have been competitive and ray chasing
performance for this title
in 2018 but it's not competitive right
now and that's especially true because
it's fully path traced
so there's no rasterization to leverage
with amd's
advantages at 1440p the 3060 ti retains
a large lead up to 57
at 46 fps average versus 29 for the 6700
xt the 6700 xt may be technically
capable of ray tracing
but it's not the ideal card for it at 4k
we recorded a validation pass just to
make sure our observations remain
correct
and that running the benchmark with rtx
extensions and khr
extensions resulted in roughly the same
performance and it did
the results were identical the 6700 xt
was limited to 13 fps
average in both instances here meanwhile
the 360 ti's advantage grew to 61
percent
with an fps average of 21. this
advantage is largely theoretical though
nobody wants to play quake 2 at 21 fps
in
2021 but it's still technically a defeat
for the 6700 xt tomb raider is fairly
lightweight in terms of ray traced
efforts so this one should do better for
the 6700 xt
rtx shadows are the only feature enabled
for this test
and that means that this is largely
still rasterization
the average for the xt in this test was
84 fps
with a 360 ti 15 percent ahead at 97 fps
the 6700 xt makes some ground back
versus quake
because of the less demanding rt effect
and specifically because it's more
rasterization heavy and already
advantaged at the 1080p lower resolution
at 1440p the 6700 xt averaged 60 fps
with the 3060 ti 10 percent ahead in
performance
and the 37d 21 a hat as before if you're
interested primarily in ray tracing
you should probably buy nvidia higher
render resolutions are unrealistic for
this tier of card
so we'll just skip 4k and move on
control is a game that we test using
dlss when possible but that's not
an option for any amd cards we have
several nvidia entries in this chart
with dlss explicitly enabled but
we also have some results in the control
benchmarks
with dls has disabled that gives you a
fair like for like comparison without
dlss as an advantage
to look at nvidia versus amd rt
performance
without the lss the 6700xt averaged 49
fps
and struggled at any higher resolution
we do have some data gathered from video
cards with dlss disabled at 4k though
the 6700 xt
only manages to 15 fps average here but
this clearly isn't resolution that this
card is meant for
with rt at least we're only looking at
these results for the sake of comparison
for relative scaling the 6700xt is just
slightly behind the 3069 ti here
while the ti is 48 percent ahead and
we've got the dlss and non-dlss results
for many of these cards
to help with a like for like or a
realistic comparison minecraft rtx is
another game that we test with dlss on
when given the option but
we are forced to run at full render
resolution with amd gpus
nothing above 1080p was playable and
even the 1080p
test result averaged an unpleasantly low
fps
the 3060 ti ran this same test with dlss
disable that 67 fps average
or 114 percent ahead of amd's gpu
again the 6700 xt is capable of ray
racing
but it isn't the card's strong suit it
did better in tomb raider
where we really only have one rt feature
to worry about finally for power
consumption we'll keep it short
in a power virus workload the rx 6700 xt
maxed out at 219 watts
right below the rtx 3070 stock result
the rtx 3060 stock card pulled 200 watts
in the same workload
so everything makes sense given the
positioning in the hierarchy
there's nothing out of line with these
results we also checked the pcie slot
draw
and that looks fine too so about 219
watts for total card power is
what you end up with with the 6700 xt
closing out then
frankly this card like the rtx 3060
is whatever it's hard to get excited
about them right now
and this isn't just trying to play to
the cheap seats
this isn't pandering to the audience
because that is what a lot of people
want to hear they don't want to see
someone talk about how great a video
card is
how great value it is because
everybody's gonna be disappointed when
they can't buy one
but this isn't trying to play to that
emotion
in all actuality it is uh just
sort of disappointing to look at the rtx
3060 and then to look at this
as reviewers because you're looking at
this thing
and the 3060 going
okay cool so in fps numbers it's
20 30 percent better than the previous
model with the same name
minus a thousand on the sku so 5700 xd
that's cool that's uplift it sounds good
then you look at the price
and realize oh okay so it's one dollar
for one percent
great that means we're in the same spot
we were when the 5700x launched or when
the 2060 launched
or the other cards before them so price
creep
it's gonna happen anyway but this is far
outpacing inflation first of all
and ultimately the name is just a name
so the manufacturers decide that well 57
the 700 xt line
we're going to bump that up to a higher
class of performance and slot something
in under it where the previous one was
the thing is though when they slot
something in under this
like let's say a 6700 non xd 6600 6500
whatever
when it is an inevitably the same price
that the 5700 xt was at launch
ignoring the later years pricing of the
card which was lower
when it comes in at the same price point
and it's the same performance or very
slightly different
plus rt hardware the real response to
that
is who cares that's complete stagnation
uh and it's just not interesting and
it's it's
this isn't good enough from nvidia or
amd
so not mad at nvidia or amd just
exceptionally disappointed
however not surprised because in this
market as we said in the intro to this
piece
amd and nvidia would be selling
themselves
short if they actually brought the
pricing down in a way that was either
one
in this case more competitive with a
30-70 or
two more competitive with their own
first party previous offerings there's
no incentive to do it
because they're going to sell it and
they'd be selling their shareholders
short
and that's what matters uh for this type
of operation
so it's just it's fine
just like the rtx 3060 it's fine and
it's hard to
lean one way or the other more than that
because
unless you're watching this in months
from now and supply is stabilized
it doesn't matter today the answer to
what you buy today
is what's in stock and short of buying
something
exceptionally bad like say some of the
zotac ones or the thermal pads
uh literally don't touch the components
there's not a lot of
things you should just hard avoid
because hard avoiding
typically means you have other options
in this case
hard avoiding means the card is so
garbage that it's going to cause you
problems later down the line
and this isn't that so the conclusion
is it's fine that's it for this one
thanks for watching subscribe for more
as always
you can go to store.camerasnexus.net to
pick up one of our tool kits or mouse
mats
they're in stock we have them we have
more stock than billion dollar companies
now
or you can go to patreon.comgamersnexus
thanks for watching
we'll see you all next time
the